the U.S has denied encouraging Ukraine
to launch strikes inside Russia after
three apparent drone attacks on targets
that Moscow blames on Kiev an Airfield
in the cork region and two air bases
further inside Russia came under attack
earlier this week Ukraine has not
claimed responsibility and Washington
stopped short of attributing the strikes
to Kiev for fear of escalating the
conflict
we have neither encouraged nor enabled
the ukrainians to strike inside of
Russia but the important thing is to
understand what ukrainians are living
through every day with the ongoing
Russian aggression against their country
and our determination to make sure that
they have in their hands along with many
other partners around the world the
equipment that they need to defend
themselves to defend their territory to
defend their freedom
DW correspondent Nick Connelly joins me
now from Kiev Nick we've just heard from
the U.S Secretary of State there about
the latest escalation what are Ukrainian
officials saying
they're keeping very very quiet there
have been some hints from kind of media
figures close to Ukrainian government
implying that this was Ukraine but I
think it's going to basically end at
that there is no interest in trying to
kind of contradict or kind of be out of
step in terms of the kind of publicity
strategy with what America what the
state department anti-blinking are
saying um and I think you know in all of
this the most important thing is that
the U.S red line was about not using U.S
equipment to strike the Russian
territory all the experts seem to agree
that this was most likely a Soviet era
drone that the ukrainians had
re-engineered and as such that you know
basically gets the U.S out of the kind
of accusation of helping Ukraine to
attack Russia proper and I think it's
very difficult to kind of cast this as
Ukraine escalating a situation where
these were the very same bases used to
attack Ukraine civilian infrastructure
this was a Ukrainian attack on Russian
military targets legitimate military
targets and I think is that I think you
know the risk of a kind of big
escalation now that's fairly limited now
are these drugs on strikes inside Russia
likely to change the war
well there are two things it's a big
political headache for Vladimir Putin
it's extraordinarily embarrassing lots
of criticism inside Russia how this was
possible were these Ukrainian agents
operating in Russia or was this just a
failure of air defenses that this was
you know a drone was able to fly that
far into Russia and then there's also
the Practical part that we're already
seeing Russia having to spread its
planes more thinly uh kind of spread
them around to avoid attack and also
take away air defenses from Russian
Force here in Ukraine so definitely lots
of problems there and you know quite a
big effect seemingly at quite a small
price for Ukraine
now the Ukrainian president visited
troops near the front line yesterday how
do you gauge things there
I mean the situation is dire specialist
in the Donetsk region really kind of
lunar Landscapes extraordinary images
coming out there very few civilians left
and the ones that are there living under
impossible conditions
um there is a sense now that basically
the ukrainians are trying to bind the
Russians there Force the Russians to
basically invest extraordinary levels of
tech and you know Manpower on the ground
exhaust themselves as was the case in
luhan's region the Summer where Russia
took a few towns like civilian it's got
huge cost and then ended up losing a lot
more territory soon after after they
were basically exhausted we had volume
zelenski in the region yesterday taking
pictures showing that unlike Vladimir
Putin he's not scared of going to the
front line so big propagandaistic effect
there lots of kind of uh you know
consternation on the part of Russian
bloggers there how is it that volodium
silinski feels so safe about going to
front lines when our president stays in
Moscow but definitely a sense that you
know for the soldiers and civilians in
donbass things are probably going to get
worse before they get any better
DW correspondent Nick Connelly there in
Kiev for us thank you Nick
Russia's invasion of Ukraine of course
has caused devastating loss of life but
both sides have been secretive about
just how many of their soldiers have
died civilian casualties are also
impossible to state with any certainty
our next report looks at the reasons why
nine months of fighting airstrikes
artillery battles and close combat in
towns across a 900 kilometer long front
line leaving thousands dead but how many
thousand is unknown
Russia stated in September that it had
lost just under 6 000 troops but the U.S
military says it's lost about a hundred
thousand on the field Ukraine recently
said that about thirteen thousand of its
soldiers had died in the war but the U.S
said its number of casualties is also
more like one hundred thousand
the US uses a variety of methods to
figure out that number including
satellite footage as well as social
media images of the battlefield
when the EU stated that one hundred
thousand Ukrainian soldiers had died
Kiev reacted with anger saying such
figures were classified and that the
government would release statistics when
the time was right the EU later
backtracked from that claim
meanwhile the low numbers Russia has
released seem meant to reassure the
public that the war is not a catastrophe
the civilian death toll another big
question the United Nations most recent
statistics 7 000 civilians dead
but the front line is too dangerous for
observers to make a real Count many
Russian occupied areas like the city of
Mario Paul where Mass Graves have been
photographed by Satellites May hold tens
of thousands more and Russia is not
letting International monitors into
those areas
Russia in general makes no comment on
the number of Civilian casualties in
Ukraine
for more on this let's bring Jenny
Mathis she's a Russia Analyst at
arborist with University in the UK why
are Ukraine uh and Russia refusing to
disclose the real numbers of their War
casualties
well in any War you see this happening
because each side has a vested interest
in downplaying the number of its own
casualties but also expanding to
whatever proportions it can the numbers
of casualties on the other side but I
think in this war in particular what
we're seeing is a Ukrainian side which
is very much concerned with operational
secrecy and has been very close-lipped
about all kinds of different details
related to its capacity its Armed Forces
its operations and this is part of their
strategy of of really trying to keep a
close eye on on information and to
prevent the enemy from you know gaining
advantages that would you know improve
their ability to wage the war but also
at maintaining morale at home and at
heaping support High internationally
because the last thing that he wants to
do is to give the impression that the
Ukrainian forces are you know beaten
that they're suffering huge losses and
they're not able to continue the war
was criticized this week for publishing
and then unpublishing information on a
high number of killed Ukrainian soldiers
so how political is this
it's hugely political
um it is really vital as far as cube is
concerned for it to maintain the levels
of support that it's being receiving
from EU countries from NATO member
states and if possible to increase that
amount and so you know Kiev is going to
be very very careful and very quick to
respond to anything which might threaten
that level of support anything that
might change the the way that Ukraine's
military effort is being perceived
around the world
now this week and we've seen drone
strikes inside Uh Russian territory in
what is seen by many as a major
escalation by Ukraine what do you see
happening this winter
well it's interesting because uh in the
the weeks and months are leading up to
the winter it was widely expected that
the winter would be a period of relative
calm that both sides would uh pull back
a bit things would be quieter they would
seek to uh you know look after their
wounded and and gain capacity and get
ready for a spring offensive but that
hasn't really happened at least not on
the Ukrainian side ukrainians seem Keen
to push ahead with every advantage that
they can to try and make as many gains
as possible because at the moment they
have the momentum they have a certain
momentum behind them they've had
successes on the field they've retaken a
lot of territory and they don't want to
lose that momentum and and risk the
possibility that it shifts over to
Russia's side and so the fact that they
are able evidently to strike behind
Russian lines to attack key
um targets with uh you know in things
like uh ammunitions and command posts
and and equipment and so on is very very
important because it does two things
well does three things really firstly it
uh reduces the capacity of Russia to
wage the war and that's absolutely vital
secondly it it creates a sense of fear
and uncertainty among Russians about
where the next strike might come from
they don't feel vulnerable they don't
feel invulnerable any longer they feel
vulnerable to Ukrainian strikes but
thirdly it demonstrates to this wider
International Community supporting
Ukraine that ukrainians are doing a very
good job at fighting this war they're
clever uh they're strategic and they're
making a real difference on the ground
University in the UK thank you very much